he's disturbed by Southie vibrates one
of the perks of being a scientist is
that unlike the rest of us you don't get
in trouble for yelling at caterpillars
that's amazing
field biologist Aaron Pomerance came
across this one in Peru and shouted at
it lower frequencies to which the
caterpillar responded by unfurling
strange tentacle-like structures called
tubercles and that's not normal well I
guess it is for the still poorly
understood tentacle caterpillar what's
fairly clear though is that this weird
behavior is an anti predator tactic a
caterpillar probably deploys the
structures by pumping them full of
humulin the arthropod equivalent of
blood is something like a bird swoops in
on the caterpillar the sound of those
wing beats might just be enough to trip
the tubercles so how does a caterpillar
hear the Predators coming well each of
those tentacles is tipped with tiny
hairs that may be picking up the
vibrations associated with sounds so
they're like ears very tentacley ears
and notice that those tips are bright
light which might serve to startle
would-be predators if that doesn't work
and the theme takes a bite of a tentacle
the structure may snap off just like a
lizard would lose its tail this is
certainly one of the world's most
bizarre caterpillars but others have
different defenses such as venomous
spines caterpillars go through all of
this trouble because there are few
things as helpless as a sluggish tube of
flesh there's really no shortage of
predators that have them on the menu but
why not just go straight into a moth or
butterfly one reason why this may be
evolutionarily beneficial is that the
caterpillars and adults still compete
for the same resources freeing up more
food in the ecosystem the downside well
every so often a scientist comes around
and yells at you crazy
tentacles oh my god